[Música]
hola bienvenidos a el debate de france24
soy santiago lópez gonzález en el marco
del octavo congreso del partido
comunista de cuba raúl castro confirmó
que se despide del poder y dejara el
cargo del primer secretario de ese
partido un cargo que ahora asumirá el
actual presidente de cuba miguel
díaz-canel castro indicó que la elección
de díaz canel no es el resultado del
azar sino porque él ha sabido formar
equipo en estos años que lleva
ejerciendo la presidencia de cuba será
la primera vez que a una persona que no
pertenece a la familia castro está al
frente de la organización política que
gobierna la isla caribeña desde el
triunfo de la revolución más detalles en
el siguiente reportaje que hemos
preparado para ustedes miguel díaz-canel
bermúdez
un día simbólico pero que no cambia el
poder del partido comunista como partido
único de cuba' los castros le dan paso a
una generación más joven designada por
ellos mismos por lo que no
necesariamente es más flexible raúl
castro- de 89 años se retiró para ceder
su cargo de primer secretario del
partido comunista cubano al presidente
de la nación miguel díaz canel gracias
por el ejemplo el empuje la fuerza y la
confianza gracias por estar y ayudarnos
a creer en nosotros mismos fue
importante muy importante su apoyo de
aliento durante estos años de
aprendizaje y formación que nos permiten
asumir hoy responsabilidades en las que
usted y fidel hicieron victoria el
secretariado del partido comunista
cubano cambió por completo su
composición y el nuevo órgano será
integrado por 14 personas 3 menos que el
anterior en las calles mientras unos
celebran el nuevo nombramiento otros
creen que todo seguirá igual
vivimos mucho por la extracción que hizo
que hizo raúl no te deje o directamente
primer set el partido y presiente al
público
castro de pruebas para el traspaso de
poder llega en un momento crítico para
cuba sumida en su peor crisis económica
en 30 años bajo el efecto de la pandemia
de kobe 19 y el fortalecimiento del
embargo estadounidense impuesto desde
1962 muchos cubanos están cansados de la
escasez las largas esperas para obtener
productos importados en un 80% y a
través de las redes sociales los más
jóvenes expresan cada vez más sus
frustraciones con el gobierno comunista
esta transición abre la puerta a muchas
preguntas que tantos cambios podrá tener
cuba- bajo esta nueva administración en
términos políticos económicos y sociales
sobre todo cuando recientemente ha
habido manifestaciones ciudadanas ha
habido también algunas reformas
económicas como veíamos en el reportaje
y la realidad política social y
económica de cuba no es la misma del
momento cuando los castró asumieron el
poder que tanto puede cambiar cuba y que
tanto esto representa simplemente
continuidad lo que hemos visto a lo
largo de las últimas décadas los
aparentes vientos de cambio en cuba si
es que se le puede decir así es el tema
de nuestro debate hoy aquí en france24 y
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
maría werlau ella es directora ejecutiva
de archivo cuba es cubano-estadounidense
nos acompaña desde la ciudad de miami en
el sur de la florida también está con
nosotros sebastián arcos casabonne él es
director asociado del instituto de
investigaciones cubanas de la
universidad de la florida también es
cubano estadounidense y también se
encuentra allí en la ciudad de miami en
el sur del estado de la florida
de eeuu les recuerdo que ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación pueden
dejar todos sus comentarios sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
en la recuerdo estamos en facebook
también nos encuentran en instagram y en
twitter como arroba france24
s sant y luego es mi cuenta personal y
la etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
puntocom y comenzamos entonces ya
tenemos las preguntas tenemos a los
invitados y tenemos el contexto quiero
comenzar entonces con mariah allí en la
ciudad de miami maría qué significa para
la revolución para el sistema político
cubano para la historia política cubana
que la familia castro ya no está en el
poder y que díaz canel asuma también la
jefatura o la o este cargo de primer
secretario del partido comunista
bueno sin duda tiene un valor simbólico
la aparente sucesión a una nueva
generación que no tiene el nombre castro
sin embargo muchos analistas con los
cuales yo concuerdo piensan que igual la
familia de la busca astro
particularmente si yo te estamos
tentando el poder es el poder detrás de
la figura de miguel díaz en el que es
a partir de la nomenclatura cubana
totalmente subordinado y leal agradó el
caso por muchísimos años y que mucha
gente piensa no ostenta poder real el
poder real ha quedado en manos de luis
alberto rodríguez lópez callejas el
yerno de raúl que maneja el conglomerado
de aesa que en realidad es donde está el
dinero en cuba la economía la economía
que cuenta el 75 por ciento de la
economía hace 75 80 hay distintas
versiones en dólares como en materia de
durán obama vamos a decir y las fuerzas
de seguridad en manos de alejandro
castro fin que es el hijo del jabón el
único hijo varón
si sebastian cuál es su opinión qué
significa entonces para la historia
cubana para la historia política para la
historia del socialismo cubano está este
cambio este nuevo episodio que tal
parece que no traerá muchos cambios
según lo que están diciendo
muchas gracias
quizás el detalle histórico más notable
es que es la primera vez que el país
está gobernado por alguien que no lleva
el apellido castro y que reúne
los poderes más importantes del gobierno
cubano que son el primer secretario del
partido que quien gobierno en cuba
y la presidencia que en el jefe de
estado esta conjunción de ambos poderes
no sucedía desde que mismo raúl castro
ocupó esas dos posiciones cuando su
hermano fidel el dictador original se
retiró en el año 2006
la transferencia se completó en el año
2008 más allá de eso
no se puede hablar de mucho más no se
puede esperar ningún cambio inmediato o
no creo que ni a corto ni a mediano
plazo ni con un cambio trascendental al
menos ningún cambio fundamental en la
naturaleza misma del régimen porque las
personas que están ocupando estos
puestos que raúl abandona son personas
que el escogido personalmente que ha
entrenado personalmente y si vemos en la
lista de los nombres nuevos que han
entrado al uno político del comité
central del partido vemos que hay un
grupo significativo de personas que son
de la absoluta confianza de grado el
castro mientras raúl castro esté vivo
ron castro seguirá gobernando en cuba
aunque sea desde el fondo y si oímos las
palabras del mismo el nuevo primer
secretario del partido del señor díaz
canel en su discurso de clausura dijo
continuaremos consultando al compañero
raúl lo cual indica perfectamente qué es
lo que pasa
mariah entonces de acuerdo a este
panorama que ustedes dos describen de lo
que significa para cuba
este cambio sale salen los castro pero
se mantiene el castrismo entonces en
este país esta estructura que
establecieron después de la revolución
del triunfo de la revolución en el 59 es
así entonces las cosas se mantendrá todo
igual y no cambiará por lo menos en
términos políticos bueno sin duda que la
hegemonía de los castros del sistema que
ellos crearon estaba o una dictadura
totalitaria bajo un modelo de
planificación central socialista hasta
cierto punto bajo el partido comunista
ellos han tenido en los últimos años un
gran dilema de cómo nombrar este nuevo
modelo ellos han tratado de buscar
maneras de supuestamente actualizar el
modelo y desde el punto de vista
ideológico está claro que
no hay una coherencia pero digamos sigue
siendo la constitución comunista y las
leyes estalinistas las que rigen el país
entonces no hay gran cambio sin embargo
se da una situación
yo creo muy interesante porque el
primero raúl castro que estamos de
acuerdo
sebastián y yo y no lo sabía pero es que
sebastián en un gran analista
que sigue detrás del poder pero raúl
castro tiene 90 años y parece que el
hijo y el yerno no se llevan y hay otras
personas que tienen otras ideas
incluyendo probablemente el mismo díaz
canel a pesar de que ha sido un
subordinado de raúl y se va a dar en
cubo una dinámica muy interesante porque
cuesta en una gran crisis económica ya
no tiene es una economía parásito
parásita desde los años 60 y no tiene
una tabla de salvar vidas como la
encontró primero en la unión soviética
luego en venezuela y esperar el
levantamiento del embargo pero la
ecuación no le ha cuajado entonces se
puede dar una dinámica muy interesante
de un descalabro de arriba desde arriba
y con las fuerzas de la sociedad civil
de la oposición pacífica tradicional que
empujan desde abajo porque hay un gran
descontento y la gente pierde el miedo y
es curioso que cuando se dio la
enfermedad de fidel y la sucesión hasta
acá aún no me gusta usar la palabra
transición porque la gente cuando habla
de transición
piense en la apertura pero fíjese en que
raúl castro logró absorber todo el poder
que estaba en manos de su hermano y la
familia de fidel se quedó atrás
entonces se puede hablar una dinámica
similar con la familia de raúl castro
sebastián aquí estamos viendo un cambio
generacional claramente todos estos
líderes de la revolución ya tienen una
edad muy avanzada pero estos cambios se
están viendo en la asamblea en la parte
política pero no en la cúpula militar y
allí los militares tienen un son los que
están sosteniendo bases fundamentales de
esta revolución esto no puede ser
también el inicio de un cambio en los
próximos meses porque también son
personas muy mayores de la parte alta de
la cúpula militar cubana
si ya está ocurriendo ya viene
ocurriendo de hecho apenas dos días
antes del inicio del congreso del
partido el antiguo ministro de las
fuerzas armadas
uno de los históricos originales de la
revolución de los años 50 también un
hombre de la entera confianza por
supuesto de raúl castro fue reemplazado
en su puesto por el general lo perdiera
que siendo un hombre delantero aunque
alza de raúl castro
digamos entre 12 y 15 años más joven
lópez miera está el alero de los 70 años
y está reemplazando a un general que ya
tenía más bastante más de 80 años así
que si estamos viendo
un reemplazo muy electo muy estudiado y
cauteloso de las figuras más importantes
en la estructura de poder por figuras
que han sido ampliamente vetadas por la
familia castro y la familia castro es un
tema que es inevitable cuando se habla
de lo que está sucediendo en cuba porque
el régimen en un momento determinado
durante más de 30 años fue un régimen
totalitario tradicional gobernado por un
caudillo que a su vez gobernaba el
partido y daba la impresión de que el
partido era quien gobernaba el país
este modelo se ha ido degenerando en un
proceso que incluso los académicos
reconocen como un post en proceso de
transición o de evolución post
totalitaria no quiere decir que total
totalitarismo haya desaparecido sino que
se transforma en una cosa distinta y
ésta lo que estamos viendo hoy en día es
un modelo clásico de un sistema
totalitario congelado donde el régimen
no se mueve apenas en lo económico las
reformas son muy tímidas y no son
suficientes para echar a andar la
economía y no se mueve absolutamente en
lo político lo que viene después hay que
esperar a que el caudillo desaparezca de
la vida pública no sólo en términos de
retiros sino que
tenemos que esperar por un velorio y un
entierro para ver qué es lo que viene
después y como decía maría muy bien lo
más probable es que veamos unas internas
en facciones que todavía no están
definidas pero que están empezando
quizás a sumar un poco
en la superficie quiénes son los líderes
posibles de esta facción dentro de esa
línea de ideas sebastián y mariah de
quiénes son esos posibles líderes pues
ahora la figura que sobresale es miguel
díaz canel por lo menos ante la
comunidad internacional por lo mando lo
que uno ve desde fuera como presidente y
ahora también como secretario del
partido
que tanto poder tiene miguel díaz canel
que tanto margen de acción tiene
sabiendo que consulta y que incluso el
mismo raúl en su discurso allí en el
ante el pleno del partido dijo que él
mantendría el pie en el estribo para
defender la revolución y defender el
socialismo eso quiere decir que suelto
un poco las riendas pero me mantengo al
mando o así por lo menos lo han
interpretado los analistas y los
politólogos que tanto margen de acción y
que tanto margen de decisión tiene
miguel díaz canel ahora que tendrá estos
dos cargos al mando maría
no mi opinión es que el poder lo ostenta
el yerno de raúl y el hijo de raúl o sea
quien controla la economía y la divisa
que entra cuba
luis alberto rodríguez lópez callejas el
que controla gaza y por otro lado las
fuerzas de seguridad de la fuerza
represiva es muy importante hay una
distinción entre el ministerio del
interior que son las fuerzas que
reprimen y mantienen el control interno
y el ejército las fuerzas armadas y ahí
es que está el poder en mi opinión yo me
sorprendería muchísimo ver que miguel
díaz canel y logre
sobre un núcleo de poder real y fugaz
por lo menos no lo veo y no es una
persona pero pero bueno puede sorprender
quien se hubiera esperado que hubiera
salido un gorbachov que hubiera logrado
el descalabro no sin intentarlo de la
unión soviética y del comunismo
soviético podría haber sorpresas pero yo
no yo no me lo espero de nivel ya está
en el de sebastián qué opina usted al
respecto qué piensa usted
y también usted no se sorprendería si se
sorprendería perdón si algo llega a
suceder como dice maría que que díaz
canel logró agrupar poder generar
consenso y agrupar gente que deje de
lado el castrismo
bueno hay que tomar en cuenta que el
seguidor díaz canel
ha llegado hasta donde ha llegado porque
raúl castro lo puso en ese puesto
díaz canel no era una persona
particularmente conocida en las esferas
del gobierno cubano ocupó la primera
posición del partido en un par de
provincias después fue el ministro de
educación superior que tampoco compuesto
particularmente distinguido y ahí fue
cogido por raúl castro para convertirse
en el primer vicepresidente de la
república ese fue el primer salto
importante antes de ser presidente y
ahora
aunque muchos pronosticaron que díaz
canel probablemente no llegaría
aparentemente ha llegado
sorprendentemente a ocupar los dos
puestos presidentes y primer secretario
ahora recordemos que él no tiene una
base de poder real más allá de la
opinión personal del caudillo round
castró él no tiene un poder popular él
no ha llegado donde ha llegado por el
voto popular por supuesto es no ha
llegado allí porque hay una facción
importante dentro del partido que nos
escogió como su candidato él está allí
porque era un castro lo puso ahí hay
rumores incluso que no se le puede dar
en muchas garantías porque son rumores
de que la misma familia de los castro no
necesariamente simpatizar con díaz canel
en el puesto que está pero está y hay
que ver en el próximo año dos años como
él puede si es que puede crear una base
de poder dentro de la estructura del
partido que tenga cierta independencia
que pueda llevar quizás el cuyo de díaz
canel porque lo que está claro es que
una vez que desaparezca raúl castro- del
escenario y acá no se va a encontrar con
una serie de poderes
muy importantes dentro del gobierno es
más obvio de todos él el ex yerno de
raúl el señor de rodríguez lópez calleja
pero hay otros está también en las
fuerzas armadas
y está por supuesto la sombra de
alejandro karting que en un momento
determinado ocupó posiciones de
inteligencia y seguridad muy importante
no las ocupa aparentemente ahora al
menos no en público ha desaparecido
completamente pero es indiscutible que
el señor díaz canel va a tener que crear
su propia base de poder para poder
sostenerse en esta posición y yo
francamente dudo que pueda sostenerse
durante mucho tiempo más allá de la
desaparición de la gente de su poder a
raúl y sin raúl ese poder es muy
inestable y ahí podría abrirse un
escenario de disputadas de poder una vez
raúl castro ya no éste podría abrirse
una disputa de poder entre estas
personas que usted ha mencionado y entre
los diferentes círculos dentro del
caudillo como lo ve usted sebastián
indiscutiblemente que ha pasado en otros
países en otros momentos históricos
similares cuando desaparece el caudillo
principal
la una que hasta este momento no han
sido visibles precisamente por la
presencia
fundamental del caudillo esas pugnas
empiezan a aparecer en la luz pública y
aunque al principio con más lentitud
pero llega un momento en que esas unas
generan una lucha interna dentro del
patín ocurrió en el partido de polonia
ocurrió al partido de hungría ocurrió en
la misma en la mismísima unión soviética
recordemos el golpe de estado militar
contra la gorda ya ha ocurrido en china
ha ocurrido en la inmensa mayoría de los
países que han pasado por la experiencia
totalitaria cubano debe ser una
excepción
hay que notar que el poder de 10 canales
es un poder eminentemente político al
ser el primer secretario del partido y
el presidente de la república pero el
poder fundamental en cuba puede girar
rápidamente a convertirse en el poder
económico y ese está en manos de otra
persona en este caso rodríguez lo que
calleja el ejemplo de putin en rusia
podría indicarnos en qué dirección puede
que se mueva la situación en cuba una
vez que raúl castro- ustedes fuera del
poder el que tiene el control de la
economía puede tomar el control de la
política que no necesariamente es fácil
que ocurra de la otra manera si
sebastián
mariah con poder o sin poder con
consenso o sin consenso el presidente es
díaz canel el secretario del partido es
díaz canel y enfrentar retos muy
importantes la situación en cuba no es
fácil no ha sido fácil a lo largo de
estos 60 años de revolución pero ahora
la coyuntura es particular es mucho más
difícil cuál quiere usted entonces que
serían esos retos importantes que tendrá
que asumir
políticos de política exterior y sobre
todo sociales y económicos bueno para el
liderazgo de cuba en este momento es
también enfrentado a una situación muy
crítica con una economía muy crítica que
no veíamos desde el periodo especial en
los 90 hay muchos de ese abastecimiento
andando el virus en cuba y casi ninguna
vacunación
ellos tienen una vacuna que estamos
ensayando pero no están realmente no se
ha probado
pues está cerrado el turismo
está bajo cierto ataque las dos
principales fuentes de ingreso de cuba
número 1 las remesas porque hay un están
paradas
hasta cierto punto no por sanciones de
eeuu por la situación económica que
están enfrentando los familiares que
mandan las remesas a cuba y demás y
porque el gobierno de eeuu no decidió
volver a la normalización e hizo van a
por razones políticas por el asunto de
venezuela y otro arte cuba juega y en
segundo lugar las misiones médicas y la
fuerza laboral en el exterior que han
habido
afortunadamente voces importantes en la
comunidad internacional que lo están
denunciando finalmente como el tráfico
de personas es y esa es la principal
fuente oficial de divisas de kubala más
conocidas son las emisiones médicas pero
no es la única es un sistema de
servidumbre
de violaciones de los derechos humanos
que ella en brasil cayó en desgracia
porque se descubrió lo que pasa es que
hay muchos aliados de juguetes están
dispuestos a participar de esto entonces
el gobierno se tiene que juzgar una
apertura de tipo económica vamos a decir
vietnamita china ellos van tratan
ensayado este modelo pero no quieren
dejar el control y el sector productivo
la economía la la productividad agrícola
etcétera se ha derrumbado y están
entonces a diferencia del período
especial tiene 30 años más de desgaste
de la infraestructura y de la
productividad del país es una situación
muy seria donde una economía que siempre
ha sido dependiente de otra que es una
economía como dije antes parásitos no
tienen otra otra alternativa que en
realidad la alternativa real es
estructural liberal en las fuerzas
económicas
y no creo que estén dispuestos de
hacerlo y esa pugna se va a estar dando
y se está dando ahora mismo hasta donde
sueltan y hasta donde recogen y mientras
tanto la población como mencioné antes
está perdiendo el miedo ya no hay
legitimidad o sea ya el modelo no tiene
la ideológica es una situación muy
complicada si ya vamos a hablar del tema
de la disidencia y también de la llegada
y el uso de internet que eso le ha dado
cierta capacidad de voz a los ciudadanos
y quiero preguntarle a sebastián por las
relaciones que tiene cuba con eeuu
este está supuesto fin del poder de
castro de raúl castro y qué
díaz canel asuma la secretaría del
partido abre alguna ventana para que
haya nuevamente una un acercamiento
entre estados unidos y cuba todo esto de
cara a esa posible apertura económica
que ellos ya han dicho que va a ser una
apertura económica pero con muchos
límites obviamente no lo van a no lo van
a poner de otra manera
yo ni siquiera usaría la frase apertura
económica van a hacer y están haciendo
hace ya un tiempo algunas reformas
económicas pero son reformas marginales
son reformas que al final han resultado
completamente ineficientes y en muchos
casos
contradictorias la ideología fundamental
del régimen recordemos que es un
reglamento totalitario marxista aunque
ellos se llaman un socialista es
esencialmente lo mismo donde el estado
es el único proveedor una de las
pero fundamentos de un régimen de este
tipo es la capacidad de proveer
económicamente a sus ciudadanos cierto
nivel de vida del régimen hoy en día es
incapaz de proveer el mínimo
a nivel de vida el problema más
fundamental que tiene el reino hoy en
día este desayuno almuerzo y comida y
ese la legislatura hits y me that
económica del régimen es desastrosa y se
suma por supuesto a la creciente falta
de legitimidad política todas las
reformas en todos estos cambios que se
han hecho en cuba en los últimos diez
años se han hecho enfocado a dos cosas
fundamentales una garantizar la
continuidad del régimen y dos convencer
a la comunidad internacional y convencer
fundamentalmente a los eeuu de que cuba
es un país que se está modernizando que
está cambiando que se está abriendo para
que a su vez esta comunidad
internacional y eeuu
se sientan mejor a la hora de invertir
en una economía como la de cuba este
experimento de obama del año 14 15 16 lo
que demostró claramente es que el
régimen cubano era precisamente quien se
negaba a continuar la apertura de la
economía una vez que eeuu decidió
cambiar su política eso explica de
muchas maneras la razón por la cual la
política regresó a una política de
sanciones e incluso se endureció
muchísimo más se celebra ante el darío
dentro
es el señor mal
anunció durante su campaña que quería
deseaba regresar una política más suave
con cuba pero el señor vaya que está
enredado en una serie de cambios
fundamentales políticos internos dentro
de los eeuu que le tienen la mayor parte
del tiempo ocupado y el tema de cuba es
un tema que le puede traer dificultades
dentro mismo del partido debemos tratar
recordemos sin gestión hay un senador
fundamental importante para las
relaciones con cuba que para él no puede
darse el lujo de perder y eso explica la
razón por la cual valle no se ha movido
o cuba y aparentemente no se va a mover
al menos en lo que queda de este año si
sebastián para puntualizar lo que le
decía a la economía pero con límites el
raúl castro en este discurso que dio
ante el pleno del partido habló también
pues de la inversión extranjera y de la
necesidad de impulsarla a pesar de las
dilaciones y obstáculos que dificultan
el desarrollo de la economía esto es un
discurso que hemos
idoia en reiteradas ocasiones pero que
de la palabra al hecho hay un largo
trecho como dice el dicho maría quiero
preguntarle por el futuro de la
disidencia por ese movimiento san isidro
que ha cogido un poco más de fuerza en
los últimos meses allí en cuba
han alzado un poco más la voz el acceso
a internet móvil en cuba desde el 2018
él ha permitido sobre todo a los jóvenes
acceder a plataformas donde han podido
experimentar otro tipo de formas para
dar a conocer la realidad de los cubanos
y hacer críticas directas al gobierno
sin duda es muy importante y son muy
valientes curiosamente estos son los
hijos de la revolución son más pro
cubano
muchos de ellos son artistas son jóvenes
son pobres vienen de barrios pobres o
sea supuestamente esta es la gente que
la respalda para lo cual se hizo esta
revolución
esto comenzó justamente porque el
gobierno cubano se como creo que con el
2018 pasó un decreto de que todas
presentación artística tenía que tener
una autorización previa del gobierno sea
si una cantante quería cantar en una
esquina con una guitarra o vender una
obra de arte casera tenía que tener la
autorización del gobierno y esto se
activó a esta sociedad civil que no es
la oposición tradicional política que ha
habido en cuba que sigue por supuesto
activa que ha sido muy reprimida pero
siguen generando personas sumamente
valientes por toda la isla entonces
aparte de eso se conjuga también que
vemos todos los días por toda la isla
los ciudadanos de a pie que se rebelan
contra las fuerzas de orden que están en
las cosas por largas horas en una
situación muy difícil con el virus con
hambre etcétera y que están ya cansados
y se da una situación explosiva en las
calles de cuba en este momento
y eso yo no creo que ante un régimen
como el cubano que tiene una estructura
de poder represivo de más de 6 décadas y
muy bien montada va a significar que de
abajo se pueda acabar con el régimen
cuba es un país que tiene una tasa de
represión mayor vamos a decir cuando se
comparan con los antiguos países del
bloque soviético y yo estudiado bastante
este tema cómo se vigila la sociedad
como se reprime muy sofisticado el
mecanismo y funciona y por eso es
difícil pensar que en un régimen
totalitario como el cubano va a venir un
elemento de abajo porque no logran
apaciguar pero está en situación de
debilitamiento en la cúpula vacío de
poder con la regla moral es muy
importante se me acaba el tiempo maria
tengo que cortar y dejar el programa
hasta acá maría werlau ya sebastián
arcos casabonne en la ciudad de miami
gracias a los dos por haber
he estado con nosotros y haber llevado
este análisis a los televidentes de
france24 un nuevo episodio nuevo
capítulo en la historia cubana y la
incertidumbre sigue en torno a los
posibles cambios que pueda haber en este
país caribeño gracias a ustedes por la
sintonía gracias por sus comentarios y
en las redes sociales pueden seguir
haciendo sus preguntas a través de las
diferentes plataformas siga con nosotros
buenas noches
[Música]